We spent a couple of videos
naming amines.
In this video, let's actually
see how they might react.
Now, to just kind of understand
what happens with
an amine, let's study
one in particular.
Let's look at ethylamine.
That's its common name, and
that's obviously going to be a
two-carbon chain, so that's the
ethyl part, connected to a
nitrogen, so that is
the amine part.
And then the nitrogen will
have two other bonds, two
hydrogens, just like that.
And if you look at the Periodic
Table, so here's our
Periodic Table right here, you
see nitrogen is in Group 5:
one, two, three, four, five.
This says Group 15, but we're
going to ignore the transition
metals for now.
So it has five valence
electrons.
When you look at it, when you
look at the bonds here, you
only see one, two, three
valence electrons.
So there's going to be two more
and they're going to be
in a lone pair, just
like that.
When you also look at the
Periodic Table, you also see
that nitrogen is pretty
electronegative.
In fact, there's only a few
elements that are more
electronegative.
But remember, electronegativity
is just how
much does it like to
hog electrons?
So it's more electronegative
than carbon.
It's to the right of carbon
and it's way more
electronegative than hydrogen.
So if you compare it, not only
does it have this lone pair of
electrons right here, but it's
also going to hog-- let me do
it in a different color.
It's also going to hog these
orange electrons that are on
the other side of the bond.
So, as we know, implicitly
there's a
carbon right over here.
There's another carbon
over here.
There's two hydrogens
We haven't drawn all
of that stuff.
But it's more electronegative
than everything it's bonded to
so its also going to attract
those electrons, so it's going
to have a partial
negative charge.
Let me make it very clear.
The partial negative charge--
that's carbon right there.
The partial negative charge
is at the nitrogen itself.
And you're going to have
slightly partial positive
charges of the carbons
and the hydrogens,
especially at the hydrogens.
And now if we just talk about
the properties of it, because
it's polar, this would actually
give it a reasonably
high melting and
boiling point.
You could imagine, amines when
they are in a solution with
other amines, they are going
to be attracted essentially
via this type of hydrogen-type
bonding.
The negative part of partial
negative nitrogens are going
to be attracted to the partially
positive hydrogens
of other amines.
Now, the hydrogen bonding for
an amines is not going to be
as strong as it will be for,
say, waters or alcohols
because waters and alcohols
involve oxygen, and oxygen is
even more electronegative
than nitrogen.
So these partial charges
are even stronger.
So that's why hydrogen bonding
is even stronger in the case
of things that have oxygen in
it like alcohol or water.
Now, with that said,
let's think about
how this might react.
I have a lone pair over here.
I also have a partial negative
charge because this guy is
more electronegative.
It seems like we have a lot of
negative action going around
the nitrogen there.
And because it has that, maybe
it would either like to give
away electrons or maybe take
hydrogens from other things.
And that, in fact, is the
case with amines.
So in general, and let me
write this down, this is
ethylamine right here, just so
we get our naming practice.
Ethylamine, this is
the common name.
We just said this is an ethyl
group attached to an amine.
And this is obviously
a primary amine.
It's only attached to one
carbon right here.
But in the case of an amine like
this, and actually out of
all of the functional groups
we will look at, out of all
the neutral functional groups we
look at, because of what we
just described, because it has
this partial negative charge,
it has this lone pair,
the nitrogen's pretty
electronegative, this is
actually the most basic.
And this isn't just
ethylamine.
This is all amines.
Let me write this down.
Amines are the most basic of the
neutral functional groups.
Obviously, something like a
hydroxide anion, it has a
negative charge.
It will want to attract
protons even more.
But this one's pretty good,
considering that it is neutral.
So given that it's basic, and
we'll also say, and it's a
related notion, it's
also nucleophilic.
And just as a reminder, when
people talk about basicity,
they're talking about how much
does something want to give
away electrons?
Or how much does it want
to take protons?
When you talk about the
nucleophilicity, or how good
of a nucleophile something is,
it's how good are you at
giving away electrons?
Or how good are you at
essentially being attracted to
protons or giving
away electrons?
And so when you talk about
basicity, you're talking about
a thermodynamic property.
When you're talking about
nucleophilicity, you're
talking about a kinetic
property.
How good is it at interacting?
The basic tells you how stable
is it once it has interacted.
So given that it's a
nucleophile, you could
imagine, I think you see where
I might be going with this.
Let me draw the ethylamine
again.
So ethylamine, I'll draw it
in a little bit simpler.
So let me draw the hydrogens
like that, and then it has
this lone pair.
Let's think about what might
happen if we have a solution
of ethylamine.
If we have ethylamine and
it's mixed in with some
bromoethane.
So that's one, two carbons
right there.
Let me draw the bromo group.
And it might not be obvious
the way I drew this
bromoethane right here.
Let me write this down.
This is bromoethane.
But I think it will be obvious
if I draw this carbon right
here and if I draw the other
two hydrogens, which are
implicitly there.
So that is one hydrogen right
there and then you have
another hydrogen over here.
And you have a good nucleophile
in the ethylamine.
So what do you think
will happen?
Oh, yeah, I also have a
good leaving group.
So you see I'm talking in the
language of Sn2 reactions.
Or really, I'm talking in the
language of nucleophilic
substitution reactions, and I'm
going to lean towards the
Sn2 direction because I have
a primary carbon here, good
leaving group, pretty
OK nucleophile.
If this was a secondary,
especially if this was a
tertiary carbon, then I
would be thinking Sn1.
Then I would say, oh, maybe
this leaves on its own.
But in an Sn2, what we're
going to have is, this
nucleophile will attack or it
will give away its electron,
so it'll give its electron
to this carbon.
And simultaneously, since this
electron is going towards the
slightly positive, the partially
positive carbon
here, this bromine can finally
take away that carbon's
electrons, and so we just
experienced an Sn2 reaction.
This is an Sn2 reaction.
And then after that is done,
the bromine will have left.
It has taken this electron.
It already had this
one over here.
It already had that one.
And actually, it had another
six electrons.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven valence electrons
for bromine.
Now, it will have eight.
So, one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, now it will
have eight.
It just took this
one right here.
It gained an electron, so it
has a negative charge.
And now let me draw this
part right here.
So we had this carbon,
that carbon.
That hydrogen is sticking--
let me draw it like this.
That hydrogen is sticking
out, just like that.
The other hydrogen
is behind it.
It's bonded to the other
carbon up here.
That's really a CH3.
It has three hydrogens off
of it implicitly there.
And now the ethylamine
has attached to it.
So let me draw that.
So that's the nitrogen.
It's bonded to one, two carbons
just like that.
And then it has a hydrogen, a
hydrogen, and then you have
this electron is still
with the nitrogen.
And then this magenta electron
has been given to the carbon,
just like that.
And since the nitrogen has given
away an electron, it now
has a positive charge.
So when you think about these
two molecules, this molecule
now has a positive charge.
This molecule right now
has a negative charge.
So they would actually be
ionically attracted to each
other, and we've actually
just formed a salt.
And this would be called-- and
this is interesting here, at
least from a naming
perspective.
You have two ethyl groups.
It might not be completely
clear.
You have one, two carbons
here, and then you have
another one, two
carbons there.
We could re-draw this as-- or
we could rewrite it as NH2.
And then we have two carbons,
and then another two carbons
just like that.
So we could call this diethyl--
we have one ethyl,
two ethyls-- so this
is diethyl.
Let me color this.
Let me do it in a different
color here.
So you have an ethyl group right
there, an ethyl group
right there, so we call this--
this is the common name for
it-- diethyl.
And then you might want to call
it diethylamine, but it's
not ammonia or it's not
derivative of ammonia anymore.
It's a derivative of ammonium.
And that's because it's now
positively charged.
This nitrogen now
has four bonds.
So this is diethylammonium.
Diethylammonium is this
molecule right here.
And if you view it as a salt,
and a salt is just an
ionically-- well, I don't want
to go into the definition
completely of a salt, but you
view this as a salt because
it's a ionically bonded
molecule, where one of the
molecules is diethylammonium,
the other one will be bromide.
This is the bromide
anion right here.
And you always list the cation
first, the positive charged
first. So this is
diethylammonium bromide, which
we were able to form with
the Sn2 reaction between
ethylamine or ethylamine
and bromoethane.
Now, we can now go under
another step here.
If we have a ton of this
ethylamine floating around, if
we have an excess, and early on
we will have a lot more of
that than we will have of this
thing right here, if we have a
ton of ethylamine floating
around-- let me draw some
ethylamine.
If we have a ton of the
ethylamine floating around, it
might be able to grab one of
the hydrogens from the
diethylammonium over here.
So you could imagine
a situation
where it grabs a hydrogen.
It essentially gives its
electron to the hydrogen, and
then that hydrogen's
electron can be
taken back by the nitrogen.
And I'll draw this as an
equilibrium because it's not
really that much more likely
that this guy takes away that
guy's electron than that guy can
go and take the electron
back, so it's a reversible
reaction.
But if that were to happen, then
this guy, this guy right
over here, will then
look like this.
You have the ethyl group bonded
to a nitrogen that only
has one hydrogen on it.
Let me just draw it like this.
A nitrogen that only has
one hydrogen on it.
And then he's bonded
to another ethyl
group right over there.
And now he has his-- so if you
view this as an electron right
there, he has his lone pair.
So he took that-- it looks like
yellow ochre, just kind
of a yellow-green color-- took
that back from the hydrogen
and is now neutral, got
an electron back.
So now, this is just
diethyl ammonia.
Actually, no.
I'm sorry.
It wouldn't be diethyl
ammonia.
It would be diethylamine.
Sorry about that.
Let me erase that.
This would be diethylamine.
It would be ammonia.
Ammonia is just NH-- let
me draw it like this.
Ammonia, just to make things
clear, is this, and that's why
my brain was telling
us to go ammonia.
And then ammonium is this.
Give away one of these electrons
to a hydrogen
proton, you have a
positive charge.
Now, when you do the common
naming, when it's kind of
ammonium derivative, you
do say diethylammonium.
And then my brain said, OK,
now that we got rid of the
hydrogen, I went back to
ammonia, so I said diethyl
ammonia, but that's wrong.
Obviously, this is now an amine,
so we used the common
naming for amines, and we get
back to diethylamine.
And then this guy over here will
turn into ethylammonium.
Sorry for all the confusion.
So this guy over here is a
nitrogen, two hydrogens, ethyl
group, and then he grabbed
another hydrogen.
So he grabbed this hydrogen
over here.
So now he has a positive charge
since he gave away that
electron over there.
So now he is ethylammonium.
But this is reversible
right here.
But what you can see, through
this Sn2 reaction, we were
able to essentailly, get rid of
one of these hydrogens and
substitute it with another
ethyl group.
We went from having a primary
amine-- this is bonded to one
carbon-- to having
a secondary amine
through this Sn2 reaction.
It's bonded to two carbons.